we all grew up watching our favorite
Disney stars and that's why we sometimes
feel like they have been one of our best
friends but now that we grew up just
like they did we have been wondering
what they have been up to make sure to
watch this video until the end to see
how Doug Cameron changed over the years
unde is News Channel if you love Disney
stars as much as we do don't forget to
subscribe to our Channel and please give
this video a big thumbs up today we are
showing you Disney famous girl stars in
real life Miley Cyrus more than ten
years ago the first episode of Hannah
Montana aired on Disney Channel right
before that 11 year old Miley Cyrus had
to go through a long audition process to
know if she was perfect to play the role
of a young teenager who was secretly a
famous pop star she first auditioned for
the role of the best friend but
producers quickly saw that she had what
it takes to be the lead and to make sure
that there would be a good chemistry
Billy Ray Cyrus got the role of her
father it was complicated for Miley
Stewart to be a megastar at only 13
years old so imagine what Miley Cyrus
felt when she understood that she would
be even more famous than the characters
she played she now admits that she felt
disconnected if who she was at that time
but she will always be grateful for the
opportunity in the platform she was
given she was able to launch her singing
career while working for Disney Channel
with meet Miley Cyrus breakout and the
times of our lives and after getting a
lot of attention by showing everyone
that she could also be a bad girl with
her controversial Bangerz era Miley
Cyrus is back to who she was before we
could even say that she is much better
now that she feels more empowered
Selena Gomez if we could use magics we
would create an awesome girl like Selena
Gomez and that's exactly what Disney
Channel did with Wizards of Waverly
Place but if there was one girl who was
happier to see this little wizard on the
screen it was the actress herself as a
child she is to perform the famous
commercial line at home
you're watching Disney Channel while
drawing the Mickey Mouse logo with a
glow stick little did she know she would
see herself on TV a few years later in
2006 we first saw her in The Suite Life
of Zack and Cody
and later she played Michaela in Hannah
Montana this is why Disney Channel knew
that she was ready for her first
starring role in Wizard of Waverly plays
princess protection program and another
cinderella story the young star was
always up to new challenges so she
started working as a singer too she
recorded many songs for the movies and
TV shows in which she had a role and
it's in 2009 that she finally released
her first album kiss and tells it seems
like it was a good idea to focus on her
music career because Selena finally has
the freedom to do whatever she wants and
she is more popular than ever
we wish nothing but the best for this
actress turned singer who is probably
the one who now inspires little girls to
be just like her Raven Symone this girl
already knew that we would be talking
about her because she can see in the
future you might not remember him but we
first saw Raven on the Disney Channel in
1999 in Z on girl of the 21st century
the network was quickly impressed by her
performance and asked her to audition
for the lead role in a new TV series and
this is how Raven Symone became Raven
Baxter from 2003 to 2007 she became a
major asset to the Disney brand later
starring in The Princess Diaries - royal
engagement the Cheetah Girls and the
Cheetah Girls - her acting career began
to slow down when she stopped working
for Disney but this is not a reason not
to make a comeback if you missed this
famous character you will be happy to
hear that she will
you know that's so raven spinoff this
time the show will follow the two
preteen children of Raven who is now
divorced
Adam bonnet the Disney Channels
worldwide executive vice president of
original programming said that Raven is
timeless they have their eyes on her for
the future and they are looking forward
to telling more stories to a new
generation with a grown-up Raven Baxter
the character has her eyes on the future
too we just can't wait to see what is
coming next
Hilary Duff she was one of the first
Disney stars and we still remember her
nowadays in 2000 the actress was cast in
a show but was dropped from this series
after only one episode she felt really
depressed but she probably now thinks
that everything happens for a reason
her mother encouraged her to never give
up on her dream and the week after she
landed the lead role in Lizzie McGuire
the show was immediately a hit and
Hilary Duff quickly became a household
name it was so popular that we also got
the chance to see her in the Lizzie
McGuire movie in 2003 her fan base also
extended to all age ranges and the
actress thought that Disney Channel
didn't give her enough credit for that
unfortunately in 2003 Disney and Hilary
Duff went their separate ways because of
creative differences
they gave her a very generous offer but
the then fifteen-year-old decided that
she didn't want to renew her contract
because she wanted to take a new
direction of her career and as we could
see she didn't need them anymore the
star released her first non-disney
studio album metamorphosis she also
starred in many movies like Cheaper by
the Dozen a Cinderella story raise your
voice and the perfect man
Hilary Duff even refused a role in 9:02
I know since she wanted to do something
more mature the star is still working on
becoming a more serious actress and she
is more beautiful than ever
Ashley Tisdale the actress began her
career in show business at only three
years old but most of us first got the
chance to see her for the first time on
Disney Channel in the suite life of zack
& cody the young star really started to
stand out a year later when she played
the role of Sharpay Evans and
School Musical she was supposed to be
the villain but she turned out to be one
of our favorite characters anyway we
were happy to see her in the two
following movies High School Musical 2
and High School Musical 3 senior year
she was so popular the Disney even made
her the hero of her own story in Shar
Peis fabulous adventure in 2011 but what
is she up to now if you don't see her a
lot that's because she mostly works as a
voice actress in TV series and movies
like Phineas and Ferb Sabrina
secrets of a teenage witch and charming
it seems like Sharpay Evans finally
found a way to work in the industry
while being a little further from the
spotlight
you probably heard people say that there
will be a new High School Musical movie
coming soon but unfortunately
Ashley Tisdale said that she wouldn't be
part of the cat however Disney revealed
that the movie will feature a character
who is Sharpay and Ryan cousin so we'll
still have a little something to remind
us of this fabulous character Skye
Jackson here comes one of the tiniest
Disney stars on our list
most of us first met the actress in
Jessie in 2011 as she played the role of
Zuri Ross in the Disney Channel sitcom
unfortunately it wasn't always easy for
her to work on this set Skye used to say
in her first interviews that debby ryan
was fantastic and that she loved to have
her the girls were even best friends
when they started working together but
in 2015 the young actress accused Debbie
of pushing and bullying her according to
a rumor however the only proof that we
have is that Skye unfollowed the actress
on Twitter
Debbie was asked about it on tumblr and
sent an intense message to a co-worker
that tends to be a mouthpiece for
parental maliciousness anyway Jessi got
cancelled after four seasons simply
because it ran its course and it became
the second longest-running sitcom on the
channel with 101 episodes we don't know
what really happened but if this story
is true Skye is probably happy to be
working on the show's spin-off bunk'd
since 2015
is out her exbest friends we saw the
young girl growing up in every season
until she became the beautiful teenager
that she is nowadays Disney seems to
love her so we bet that we will be
seeing her again soon enough weather and
bunk'd or is the main character of a new
TV series zendaya did you know that the
name of the actress actually means to
give thanks and we are thanking Disney
for giving us the chance to see this
young woman on TV it all started in 2010
in the sitcom shake it up where she
played the role of rocky blue it was the
first role she ever had and we could
already see that this girl was made for
this job but zendaya was looking for
more just like many other Disney girls
she landed a leading role built a fan
base and began a music career when shake
it up ended we had the chance to see her
once again in many music videos but the
Disney career was not over yet for the
young actress instead of focusing on
singing she decided to go back to Disney
to star in KC undercover but she had one
condition she wanted to be a star and a
producer with more power
she wanted a badass female protagonist
and this is how she became a smart
teenager born in a family of spies the
actress wanted to see more people of
color on television and she thinks that
she successfully made a show that not
only allows for representation but sees
girls in a powerful and strong position
zendaya is the kind of role model that
we want to see on the Disney Channel
Bella Thorne we don't know who was
better Cece Jones or rocky blue but one
thing is sure what we loved the most was
seeing these two girls together and
shake it up from 2010-2013 unfortunately
the two girls weren't really happy to
work together in the first season the
actress said that she was put in a very
unfortunate position where she and
zendaya had to compete against each
other it made the whole season feel
awkward for them Bella said that she
wanted to love her friends but
people kept asking who was better it is
not until the second season that they
finally talked about this started crying
and became best friend when they finally
wrapped they stayed supportive even
guest-starring on each other's new shows
well zendaya kept working for Disney
Channel Bella Thorne knew that she had
better things to do actually she never
wanted to be a Disney Channel star at
the audition she said that she had no
talent
and didn't know why she was here but no
one believed her her family was going to
live on the street if she didn't have
that role so she had to accept the offer
now the actress keeps herself busy with
roles and films like the death and life
of John F Dunivant
and assassination nation she is finally
doing what she loves while still being
an actress we couldn't be happier for
her
Demi Lovato this actress turned singer
was born to be a star when she was
younger she won several pallet contests
and started her showbusiness career at
only ten years old
it's in 2007 that she began working with
the Disney Channel with her role in as
the bell rings her role on the show
ended but that was because something
better was coming for her she was cast
as Mitchie Torres in the movie Camp Rock
Demi Lovato was one of the luckiest
girls at the time because she had the
chance to work with the Jonas Brothers
and record three songs with them then in
2009 she starred in princess protection
program with her friend Selena Gomez and
later came back with the Jonas Brothers
in Camp Rock to the final gym she was so
good the disney saw that she deserved to
be the lead in her own sitcom and this
is how she became the star of sunny with
a chance from 2009 to 2011 during this
time she was already working on her
singing career as she released her debut
album don't forget in 2008 it debuted at
number 2 on the Billboard 200 charts so
we could say that Demi Lovato was meant
to be a singer and that's exactly what
she has been doing for the past years
with her following albums here we go
again and unbroken this girl has too
much talent she needs to give us a
little bit of her skills
Dov Cameron we think that it was love at
first
like when we first saw Duff Cameron on
our television screens and we were so
lucky that we got two actresses for the
price of one as she played both lead
roles in Liv and Maddie unfortunately it
was difficult for her to work so hard
she felt really anxious she opened up
about this during the Q&A on Twitter and
she wasn't shy to talk about her
struggles even if mental health is often
taboo dove Cameron said that being
anxious made her much more disciplined
with her thoughts so it has been a
blessing in disguise she said that it's
not about hiding it it's about genuinely
embracing acknowledging and managing it
and this is what she did by spending
time alone laughing getting in touch
with her body therapy sleeps and
exercise this is how the actors was
ready for another challenge in
descendants we got the chance to see the
bad side of her but also realized that
Duff Cameron would always end up being a
nice girl the young actress is now more
mature than she was before and it's
always great to see her smiling is there
any other Disney famous girl star that
you would like us to talk about don't be
shy to tell us who it is in the comments
section we love to know what you think
and that's it for Disney famous girl
stars in real life for more stories like
this make sure you watch 10 Jessie dark
secrets Disney tried to hide thanks for
watching
[Music]